[Music]
president Trump fired back at critics
who claim that merely meeting with the
North Korean leader Kim jong-un would be
a major concession the president tweeted
wow we haven't given up anything
meanwhile Kim recently announced he's
suspending missile and nuclear tests
let's discuss the meetings prospects for
success with Time magazine foreign
affairs columnist Ian Bremmer
his new book US versus them the failure
of globalism I have my copy tabbed in
thank you out tomorrow look I actually
it's about you can tell I'm still in my
mind in law school actually yellow tabs
on your book and it's great to have you
on because this really is I think with
all the investigation mania going on and
all the daily you know food fight we see
in Washington this could be and could be
an unbelievable development and there's
a lot of ifs but for the president not
to get even a modicum of of you know
praise or respect for the fact that
we're at least taking a different
approach to North Korea with all the
predictions of of global unrest and he's
gonna start World War three this is
something this is quite something
Trump clearly deserves credit on this I
mean it was the fact that he was willing
to push hard that brought the Chinese to
the table supporting us driven Security
Council resolutions and squeezing them
on sanctions that concerned the North
Koreans had got them to show up at the
Olympics it got them to be willing to
engage with the South Koreans the
Chinese have summits that they had never
had before and also agree to suspend
missile testing and nuclear testing
without offering anything from the
United States no we have offered them a
summit they want that it provides
legitimacy but if you ask who's done
more bending so far the North Koreans or
the United States it's clearly the North
Koreans that's very far from saying
we're gonna get to denuclearization on
the part of Pyongyang but absolutely
there's more of a chance that we see a
breakthrough today than there was six
months ago now you made an interesting
tweet you sent an interesting tweet
about the Nobel Peace Prize tell us well
only the fact that if it were true that
Trump was able to actually not only get
the North Koreans to the table but come
to a resolution that actually got us
away from nuclear missiles pointing at
each other that he deserve a Nobel much
more than Obama did when he got at the
beginning when he came in and didn't do
anything I mean it was it's a
politicized prize we've known that for a
long time
I do believe that there's more of a
chance that we end up blowing each other
up but I also think there's more of a
chance that we get to a real resolution
I think people need to understand that
that so far on North Korea the signs
have been more positive than negative
yeah I mean for the madman theory or
whoever it was the calling him Rocket
Man and I mean the Democrats let's just
play a few of these sound bites the
Democrats have gone absolutely bonkers
leading up to this announcement about
the summit and I think we have some of
the elements let's watch one of the
things we've discovered about this new
president is he has no clue about how to
deal with foreign matters he's dangerous
and he should not be talking with this
kind of bluster and I'm hopeful that
somebody at the White House will pull
his coat and tell him to stop it
this is not through the way to leave
this country he is doing none of the
things necessary to achieve a real
diplomatic breakthrough on North Korea
this is a mess that North Korea has
created but President Trump has made it
more difficult to deal with and look
he's made mistakes on foreign policy
North Korea so far is not one of them
again we've had both a democratic and a
Republican president over the course the
last decade that's allowed the North
Korean situation to only get worse more
nuclear capabilities more missile
capabilities more cyber capabilities
finally we get the Chinese to the table
we get the North Koreans to the table on
balance since Trump has come in despite
the fact that as an important policy
experience we have more opportunities
with the North Koreans than we had
before and I want to talk about your
book which I've been able to read
bunches of you grew up in Chelsea
Massachusetts and you talked about how
in in Chelsea it was you know middle
class area and how people now like many
parts of the country before Trump I
think especially people are angry
because they feel like no longer is it
just hard work in an education and
you're guaranteeing to get ahead the
globalization has people feel has failed
them worried more about other countries
than it did what was going on here at
home tell us well I wish it was a
middle-class background it was a that
would have been aspirational was a
prettty was the projects it was a
working-class background and there were
no globalists there were no capitalists
that I grew up with because they had no
capital and I think the reason why so
many people are willing to vote against
the establishment in the United States
is because they feel like both on
economics on culture on security on
technology on every issue that the
establishment left and right has been
talking about that they've been left
behind and I've seen a lot of people
over the last couple years a year and a
half been willing to blame Trump for the
us-versus-them that we are facing right
now as a country when we in reality you
know us versus them is responsible for
Trump take a lot twenty years for us
versus them 25 years I'd say the book is
us versus them and come on radio this
week a really interesting read would
really appreciate it